We've all been there before: sitting in a
packed theater, staring up at the silver screen,
scratching our heads wondering where we've
seen a certain actor before.
In the case of the actress who stars in the
2019 horror sequel 47 Meters Down: Uncaged,
she won't catch your eye for any of her previous
work on film or television.
Rather, it's down to her family name and how
it's placed her in the public eye from a very
young age and put her on a path toward stardom.
Leading 47 Meters Down: Uncaged, the sequel
to 2017's 47 Meters Down, is Sistine Rose
Stallone, who has a very famous father in
Rocky and Rambo franchise star Sylvester Stallone.
"Seems like lately everybody wants to beat
me up."
The striking 21-year-old makes her feature
film debut in Uncaged, playing a teenage girl
named Nicole who dives into a ruined underwater
city with three of her closest friends.
Much to their horror, the four girls soon
discover that the secret city is home to threats
of all kinds, including the deadliest sharks
known to man.
The younger Stallone has been in the Hollywood
spotlight for a long time, thanks to her easily
recognizable father.
Throughout her life, she's appeared alongside
her dear ol' dad at movie premieres, glitzy
Hollywood outings, and film festivals like
Cannes.
So if you feel like you've seen her dirty
blonde hair and brown eyes somewhere before,
it's likely that you saw a snap of Sistine
and Sylvester together on the red carpet.
You may have also seen her up on the Golden
Globe Awards stage in 2017 as Miss Golden
Globe, an honor given to up-and-coming children
of prominent Hollywood celebrities.
While Stallone hit the genetic jackpot in
being the daughter of a Hollywood legend and
former model Jennifer Flavin, she isn't solely
relying on her famous family to carve out
a career for herself.
Of course, her conventional good looks and
surname that's instantly linkable to her father
have helped set her up for fame, as evidenced
by her one million-plus followers on Instagram,
but Stallone worked hard to establish herself
as a model prior to jumping into the acting
world.
"I don't normally wear a red lip, but I love
what they did, and it's kind of faded."
She signed with IMG Models in 2016, and has
walked in Dolce & Gabbana and Chanel fashion
shows.
She's also been on the cover of Town & Country
and Elle Russia.
Ironically enough, while Stallone has said
she's always dreamt of modeling and even loves
it so much that she would work for free, she
once said that she could never picture herself
getting into acting.
She told The Hollywood Reporter in January
2017,
"As for me, I don't think I could ever act.
I'm good for modeling because I don't have
to talk.
[Acting] is something you're born with."
With a mother like Jennifer Flavin, Sistine
Rose was bound to try her hand at modeling,
and with a father like Sylvester Stallone,
how could she not be born with the acting
gene firmly in place?
She's got the best of both worlds; let's just
hope that her acting chops are as impressive
as her father's.
"He keeps calling my name, 'I want to go home,
Johnny!
I want to drive my Chevy.'
But I couldn't find his f---ing legs!
I can't find your legs!"
Catch Sistine Rose Stallone in 47 Meters Down:
Uncaged when the horror film swims into theaters
on August 16.
"Now, off to get some tea!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.